[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 voici les principaux titres en
images de ce 24 janvier 2010 est le
président du sénat présent à elancourt
hier pour une visite de terrain un
déplacement pour apporter son soutien au
futur commissariat d'agglomération et
aux réussites sociales et scolaires
demain mercredi le musée de la ville va
ouvrir ses portes après plusieurs mois
de travaux nouvel espace pour de
nouvelles expositions visites guidées
quelques heures avant l'arrivée des
premiers visiteurs répliquent comme
chaque mardi un nouveau portrait d'une
personnalité blinoise rencontre
aujourd'hui avec le marquis de breteuil
est dé ses 21 ans il s'est battu pour
conserver la bâtisse familiale que des
promoteurs s'apprêtait à transformer en
un hôtel politique donc pour débuter et
le déplacement de gérard larcher du côté
a des longs cours le président du sénat
en visite dans le cadre de ses
rencontres avec le territoire au
programme hier éducation et sécurité
alors languit nicolas kirillovitch
direction le commissariat d'elancourt
accompagné de la sénatrice des yvelines
sophie primas le président du sénat a pu
constater lui même l'état de dégradation
du bâtiment 320 policiers y travaillent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
commissaire comment vous vous trouvez
urgence c'est sans doute la première
urgence des yvelines de pas simplement
rénover mais de construire un nouvel
hôtel de police qui servent à l'ensemble
de la circonscription les conditions
dans lequel travail des fonctionnaires
de police
et j'allais dire inadmissible la
rénovation de ce commissariat
d'agglomération est un dossier vieux de
20 ans mais les choses semblent
progresser en décembre valérie pécresse
avait annoncé que la région
ile-de-france financerait une partie des
travaux vont émigrer mais sûr satisfait
de voir que
le président du sénat bien sûr aussi est
sensible à cette structure en plus on a
géré bien entendu la sensibilité de
trappes la verrière qui sont quand même
des communes classées un peu sensible
donc donc mobilisation en tout cas
général le président du sénat a
poursuivi sa visite à l'école vibrante
d'elancourt dans cette classe tous les
enfants des gaines fièrement leurs
tablettes
le numérique est au coeur de la
pédagogie on est ici dans une école qui
prépare le futur ya les enfants bien
longtemps qu'ils vont assez facilement
au sol et ceux qui ont besoin d'un
soutien et le numérique semble et
apporter la journée s'est enfin achevée
par une rencontre avec les élus de la
ville où ont été abordés d'autres sujets
comme le logement dans l'actualité
locale également demain mercredi 25
janvier le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines basé sur la commune
de montigny le bretonneux va rouvrir ses
portes après un déménagement et 18 mois
de travaux le musée accueillera à
nouveau les visiteurs les espaces sont
plus grands plus lumineux nous l'avons
visitée lors des tout derniers
préparatifs mélanie poquet l'entrée sous
les escaliers c'est terminé le musée de
la ville a intégré ses nouveaux locaux à
deux pas nous voici dans le nouveau
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors nouveau parce que c'est un nouveau
lieu d'abord on emménage dans l'est dans
le bâtiment qui abrite la médiathèque du
canal c'est aussi un nouvel aménagement
intérieur avec des espaces et des
contenus complètement repensé
plus de 280 mètres carrés trois espaces
pour quelques-uns des 6000 objets de la
collection des espaces plus lumineux et
plus accessible à tous le nouveau musée
est de plain pied
il y avait besoin de doubler cet espace
parce que celui du musée était devenu
vraiment très restreint dans l'ancien
musée
ça fait plaisir de voir
un an et demi de travail de travaux
aussi qu'ils aboutissent et qui
aboutissent a vraiment quelque chose de
concret on a hâte que les visiteurs
reviennent et rendre sa vie au musée
surface plus grande dit aussi exposition
repenser la permanente qui retrace
l'histoire de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines voies plus larges de
la préhistoire à nos jours
s'il est de niveau intercommunal c'est
qu'en fait il retrace bien toute
l'histoire de la ville
et en plus ils portent le label art et
histoire et en fait on s'aperçoit et
vous l'avez vu au début de l'exposition
en fait les villages avaient une origine
historique importante et ça c'est bien
de rappeler tout ça et en même temps
montre toutes les toute l'évolution puis
comme ça on tient compte aussi un petit
peu de l'évolution du territoire
puisqu'on viennent intégrer ça que cinq
nouvelles villes
une exposition temporaire est proposée
en parallèle une chaque année le musée a
tiré avant sa fermeture environ dix
mille visiteurs par an dès le 25 janvier
les huit membres de l'équipe seront
prêts à les accueillir de nouveaux
direction guyancourt à présent ou samedi
dernier a été organisé le premier forum
de la météo météo et climat à
destination du grand public
atelier expérience rencontre journée est
rythmée par des spécialistes comme a pu
le constater sur place nicolas d'ambri
accompagnée de camille lambert
effet de serre réchauffement climatique
courants marins des notions pas toujours
évidente à expliquer aux plus jeunes à
guyancourt un forum de la météo et du
climat était proposée au public le 21
janvier
un moyen ludique d'aborder des
thématiques importantes
les intervenants avec lesquels on
travaille s'appelle ils sont issus de
l'association les savants fous
donc ça fait quelques années qu'on
travaille avec eux etc des animateurs
scientifiques qui sont formés pour
intervenir auprès du public du jeune
public
c'est un outil de sensibilisation c'est
de l'information et sous la direction du
professeur bidibulle les curieux
deviennent apprentis savant alors ils
ont commencé une petite expérience pour
comprendre que la biomasse dégage du co2
dans l'atmosphère avec des levures du
sud de l'eau chaude et en dégageant le
co2 ça fait gonfler un ballon
là on est en train de faire des tornades
donc on voit un petit peu comment
fonctionne le phénomène de la tornade
entre l'eau douce
le 2 mai dans le doubs shell était plus
légère et aussi bas qu avec du co2 on
pouvait faire des saints ballon on a
fait des expériences avec une bouteille
où il y avait de l'eau dedans et du
colorant et
ensuite on a retourné la bouteille on
avait vu que ça faisait internet
j'ai appelé des nouvelles choses et ça
m'a bien plu les 60 enfants inscrits aux
ateliers ont pu repartir avec leur
expérience pour les réaliser en famille
en partenariat avec le secteur
développement durable et météo france ce
forum aura réuni plus d'une centaine de
personnes
nous poursuivons notre semaine à la
découverte des métiers rares aujourd'hui
nous poussons à les portes d'un atelier
de dorures averse à une pratique
artisanale qui n'a pas pris une ride en
reportage camille lambert et nicolas
d'andré de fines feuilles d'or très
fragile comme matériaux de production
marlène voisin est artisan d'horreur
elle travaille sur un cadran siens après
l'avoir redimensionner elle peut
commencer à le doré donc on utilise le
souffle le couteau et des petits
pinceaux
vous avez la palette et en poils de
martre et puis des petits pinceaux en
petits gris qui vont servir à appuyer la
feuille d'or ça c'est que de l'eau c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle ça une dorure à la
détrempe parce que notre support lui
qu'on a appliqué est à base de colle
donc quand on vient l'humidifier sarah
vit de la colle c'est de la colle de
peau de lapin et du coup quand ça sèche
et ben ça tient arrivé en 2008 à
versailles pour ouvrir son atelier
l'artisan à la dorure dans la main
depuis son adolescence j'ai commencé
j'avais 15 ans quand je me suis mis
à m'orienter là dedans donc c'est un
apprentissage qui dure sur trois ans max
et à peut-être de dorures le plus dur
c'est d'arriver à trouver un formateur
en fait quelqu'un qui veuille bien nous
former parce qu'on n'est pas en train
avec un chiffre d'affaires de 55 mille
euros marlène s'appuie sur des clients
connaisseurs autres facteurs faisant la
rareté de ce métier les prix élevés
les clients sont assez fidèles puissent
et des métiers bon on n'est pas nombreux
donc en fait c'est beaucoup de bouche à
oreille aussi après on travaille aussi
pour des musées des hôtels particuliers
des professionnels aussi
donc dans l'ensemble je pense qu'on va
être 150 200 à peu près à tourner sur
plusieurs années pour obtenir une dorure
de qualité toutes les étapes sont
importantes cadres miroirs ou boiseries
marlène travail plusieurs objets datant
du 16e au 20e siècle
sa restauration la plus marquante une
table de gibier d'époque louis xiv
les gens viennent avec leurs cadres leur
glace et on
on repositionne de la feuille d'or
dedans c'est un métier qui n'a pas
changé au niveau des techniques par
rapport au xviie xviiie siècle on
utilise les mêmes techniques les mêmes
produits tout est artisanal en fait pour
ce cadre sculptés en bois du xviiie
siècle
l'artisan démontre sa polyvalence est
essentielle dans l'exercice de son
activité
on vient faire tout un travail de
ponçage et dort parures avec les petits
faire pour redonner toutes les nervures
de la sculpture malgré sa rareté la
dorure perdure à travers les siècles et
les techniques avec notamment grâce à la
transmission du savoir faire comme
chaque mardi nous vous proposons à
nouveau portrait d'un yvelinois d'une
yvelinoise emblématique aujourd'hui
rencontre avec le marquis henri-françois
de breteuil qui s'occupe encore
aujourd'hui de cette propriété qui est
devenu l'un des lieux les plus
touristiques des yvelines
le parmi ses portraits de famille on a
des ministres de la famille il y ait
trois ministre soûlé bourbon louis de
recueil qui verriez-vous qui est donc
ministre des finances de louis xiv son
passé sa vie semble tout droit sortie
d'un livre d'histoire henri-françois de
bretagne en décembre 1943 paris le
dixième marquis de sa famille après
avoir passé sa jeunesse dans la ville
lumière et décide en 1967 de s'installer
dans ce château de famille construit à
choisel dans les yvelines au xviie
siècle sous le règne d'henri iv
la structure était à l'abandon depuis
1945 qui avait failli tomber aux mains
des promoteurs pendant cette période
moi j'adorais ce château depuis que je
suis tout petit la première fois que je
suis venu ici je crois que j'avais 5 ans
et je m'en souviens encore avec le
cuisinier du château qui avait connu le
roi edward said les grandes
manifestations et caetera et j'estimais
que c'était mon droit et l'amour je vais
pour ce lieu qui devait m'amener à le
conserver pour préserver les lieux henri
françois de breteuil a démarré dès la
fin des années 60 une vaste opération de
restauration
en parallèle le marquis décide d'ouvrir
ses portes au public en 1969 avec 5000
visiteurs dès sa première année pour
leur raconter l'histoire de ses ancêtres
le propriétaire décide de recréer les
grands moments historiques de sa famille
grâce à des personnages de cirque créé
par le musée grévin
nous retrouvons en 1881 en compagnie de
mon grand père henri le 8e art qui de
breteuil du roi edouard 7 au milieu qui
est en fait prince de galles l'époque
qui sera roi un peu plus tard et de
gambetta et les trois personnages
s'entendre pour se dire qu'il faut
maintenant rapprocher la france et
l'angleterre en vue de ce que l'on
appellera plus tard l'entente cordiale
le marquis décide également de se lancer
dans les années 70 dans les célèbres
contes de perrault pour rendre hommage à
son ancêtre louis de breteuil ministre
des finances sous louis xiv et qui avait
eu à charles perrault comme
collaborateur aujourd'hui 800 sont
représentés
c'est beaucoup plus gai d'introduire des
personnages des contes
que des personnages de la vie du château
d'autres fois c'est que c'est ça l'idée
qu'ont eue en introduisant le chat botté
cendrillon et d'autres et ça nous a
porté chance parce que c'est vrai que
dans l'esprit du public
le château est beaucoup devenu le
château des comtes aujourd'hui encore
des jardiniers des ouvriers des équipes
d'entretien travaillent quotidiennement
dans la structure pour restaurer
moderniser le château bien sûr qu'il ya
tout souvent des travaux à faire et
notre rôle est de choisir les couleurs
de restaurer l'immeuble de restaurer les
tableaux cette pièce a été restauré l'an
dernier par exemple entièrement avec ce
beau bleu on est un peu chef de chef de
chantier comme vous le dites parce qu'il
ya tout le temps tout le temps des
travaux à faire un travail qui paye
aujourd'hui le château est visité par
près de 125 mille personnes tous les ans
l'histoire n'est pas encore terminée
elle est dernière cérémonie de voeux se
déroule en ce moment pour les élus hier
c'était au tour de michel laugier le
maire de montigny le bretonneux le tout
devant un invité de marque robert
marchand vous vous en souvenez il a
battu le record sur piste au vélodrome
et il a fait le déplacement pour
recevoir la médaille de la ville depuis
la ferme du maine et le maire a rappelé
l'ouverture au cours de l'année de la
maison de retraite dans le parc du
château de la coudre il a insisté sur le
logement également et puis une annonce
et qui a également ravi l'assemblée le
centre commercial sqy ouest va connaître
une deuxième vie un nouveau projet de
réaménagement a été validée
tous les détails dans notre édition du 7
8 les invités de demain mercredi
et puis toujours dans la série moon dans
le cadre des cérémonies de voeux le
maire de coignières jean-pierre sevestre
à lui présenté et ses voeux en fin de
semaine dernière devant notamment le
président du sénat gérard larcher il a
évoqué la mise en place du plan local
d'urbanisme écoutez c'est une année
charnière pour nous car il faut prendre
les grandes décisions pour ce qui
concerne coignières 2030 2035 et je
pense que c'est un pour le mandat c'est
quelque chose de très très important
mais pourquoi nière c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel
maintenant effectivement nous devons
avoir une transformation effectivement
nous avons bien sûr des secteurs
commerciaux qui sont importants mais
nous avons aussi un besoin si vous
voulez de modifier ces secteurs
commerciaux de les rendre plus moderne
mais également de créer une mixité et
nous refermons cette édition du journal
de la rédaction à ripley disponible sur
notre site internet est également sur
notre application mobile très belle
soirée
[Musique]